since the hubble space telescope went
into orbit back in april 1990 it has
sent back a ton of incredible photos
each has its own story but one of
Hubble's greatest images is this one
from 1995 this is a snapshot of nearly
the entire history of the universe in
the first of its kind
the Hubble Deep Field is an unusual
image that came from an unusual process
typically astronomers apply to use
Hubble to look at a particular known
object you want to study a star okay you
know what stars are going to study you
point the telescope to ten star that's
Robert Williams he became director of
the telescope in 1983 it was his
decision to create the Deep Field image
by pointing the telescope at nothing in
particular what we were doing basically
was just the opposite we were trying to
find a sort of an indiscriminate area of
sky where no observation had been made
before they wanted to test how well
Hubble could serve a very distant
galaxies but they didn't know what
they'd see and it wasn't a great time to
be trying new things after spending two
billion dollars for twelve years to have
this kind of unexpected very large
mistake take place the Hubble team was
still repairing the reputation of the
telescope after a flaw in the main
mirror produced blurry images for nearly
three years we were the brunt of jokes
and newspapers political cartoons
you know the Johnny Carson show as it
was being made fun of for having made
such a monumental screw-up of Spenser an
expensive project NASA sent astronauts
on a five-day mission to install a
module that would fix the problem and it
worked so Williams team spent 1995
planning the Deep Field observation for
one thing they had to decide where to
point the telescope the goal was to see
far beyond our galaxy so the spot needed
to be away from the Galactic plane of
the Milky Way and away from any known
large galaxy clusters they didn't want
anything bright to block the view and to
get continuous observations that needed
to be a location that wouldn't be
obscured when Hubble went around the
earth as it does every hour and a half
or so they settled on a region just
above the Big Dipper a dark unremarkable
peephole into the universe the field of
view was extremely narrow astronomers
measured the apparent size of objects in
the sky and angular degrees and a degree
can be divided into 60 arc minutes
from Earth the moon is about half a
degree across around 30 arc minutes but
the area that Hubble photographed was
just 2.6 arc minutes across little
larger than a pinhead at arm's length
the Nene patch of sky the observations
began on December 18 1995 collecting
four different wavelengths of light and
over the next 10 days the telescope took
342 images of that teeny patch of sky we
will relieve that we were getting good
data but we had to keep adding it up and
so it wasn't until 10 days and we
realized how we really got something
there are a few nearby stars in the
image but pretty much all the other
objects here including these tiny blue
dots they're galaxies the light from
these different galaxies has been
traveling for vastly different amounts
of time so the furthest galaxies are
shown pretty early in their evolution
more than 12 billion years ago that's
just a billion and a half years after
the Big Bang it's as if you could point
a telescope across the earth and
actually photograph ancient Egypt with a
Neanderthal in the background and then
further back there's a dinosaur the
research team sampled another tiny spot
two years later this time in the
southern sky we wanted to know okay then
we got one spot of the sky you never
know maybe it was some weird spot so we
thought it was important to repeat the
observation the datasets boosted
estimates of the total number of
galaxies they allowed researchers to
track the history of star formation
through the universe and they helps
confirm the bottom-up theory of galaxy
formation by revealing galaxies that are
small and irregular early in their
evolution but one of the most important
legacies of the Hubble Deep Field is how
it changed the culture of astronomy
until this time astronomy had a history
of people taking the data and keeping it
to themselves until they had fully
analyzed it after all this is
intellectual property instead of
hoarding the discoveries embedded in the
data set Williams and his team formatted
and released it immediately to the wider
scientific community it's been cited in
hundreds of papers nowadays it is much
more common for people to take
interesting observations and make the
data available to the public even
they might have a right to keep it for a
certain period of time to themselves
thanks to servicing missions that
installed more advanced cameras Hubble
has since made even deeper Deep Field
images and those data too were released
to the public I think it moves forward a
march of human understanding human
knowledge tremendously and the Hubble
Deep Field did that